- [Instructor] What
we're going to try to do
is use our powers of calculus to
find this blue area right over here.
What this blue area is is the area
in between successive loops of
the graph, the polar graph.
R of theta is equal to
three theta sin theta.
I'm graphing it in polar coordinates here.
Just to make sure we understand
what's going on, this first loop gets
traced out when theta
goes between zero and pi,
so this is zero is less than or equal
to theta is less than or equal to pi.
That makes sense, when theta is zero,
this whole thing is zero, but then
as theta increases, our
R increases as well.
But then as theta goes back to
approaching pi, remember sin of pi
is zero, so then this thing will
approach zero again, so that makes sense.
Then as we go from pi to two pi,
you might expect to see some type
of a graph down here, but what you need
to realize is when we
go from pi to two pi,
sin of those thetas are gonna be negative.
So what it does is it flips over,
so instead of having an R right over
here in the third quadrant, when we're
a little past theta being a little bit
more than pi, since R would be negative,
it flips over and then it
ends up right over there.
Between theta from pi to two pi,
we actually trace out this second
circle right over here, this outer one.
It makes sense that the radius is
getting larger because we have
this three theta right over here.
As theta is getting larger and larger
in magnitude, we should say the
magnitude of our R is getting larger.
It turns out that the R would have been
up here if it was positive, but then
it goes negative, it goes out here,
but it has a larger and larger
magnitude because of this three theta.
With that out of the way, let's
think about how we find this area.
In general, if you're looking at
a polar curve and if you want to find
an area, the general notion is
you would go from theta is equal
to, let's just call it alpha, to
theta is equal to beta, so this
would be your bounds on your angle.
What you do, and we've shown this,
we've given you the intuition for it
in previous videos, it would be
one half times R of theta squared D theta,
is the general formula for finding
the area inside of a polar curve.
But what we're trying to do here is
find the area between two successive loops
for this polar curve, where as theta
goes from zero to two
pi, so how do we do that?
One way to do that, we can find
the total area in this larger loop,
and then subtract from that the
area in the smaller loop right over here.
How do we do that?
At any point, if you get inspired,
pause the video, it's always good for you
to try to work it through yourself
than just passively
watch me work through it.
Let's do it together, so
what's the area of this
outer circle if we include
this right over here?
That's going to be the integral.
Remember, the outer circle gets traced
out as we go from pi to two pi,
and it'd be one half times all
of this business squared, so three theta
sin of theta squared, D theta.
That's the outer circle,
and then from that we
want to subtract the area
of this inner circle.
Minus, what are the bounds there?
We said we'd trace out that inner circle
as we go from zero to pi, zero to pi,
one half times three theta sin of
theta squared, D theta.
It turns out that these are not
trivial integrals to solve on your own,
but we have tools, in fact, if you're
taking a lot of classes they expect
you to be able to use tools.
If you're taking AP Calculus BC,
they would expect you to be able to
use a graphing calculator, so that's
what we're gonna do right now in
order to calculate this quantity,
or to calculate this area, so let
me get out my TI-84
emulator, there we have it.
Let's see, I want you
to see my keystrokes,
so let me see if I can remember that.
The first, well it's the same thing
over again, it's just different bounds.
The first time, what you want to do
is you want to go to the math functions,
math, and then you see right over
here this is your definite
integral function.
I'm just gonna scroll down there,
to the definite integral and this
TI-84 Plus CE I guess, writes it in
nice, definite integral notation.
Sometimes you'll just see that
FN int open parentheses and then
you write the expression, you say
what your integrating with respect
to and then you give the bounds,
but here it's pretty clear.
Remember that blue
integral right over there,
I want to go from pi, so I'll do
second, that's the pi
button right over here,
pi to two pi, two second pi, and then
I'm going to have one
divided by two times,
and I'm just gonna do
it with respect to X,
it doesn't matter if I do all the thetas,
instead of thetas I use Xs, so I'm
gonna have, and I'm just doing that to
make it easy to type into the calculator.
This is going to be three X sin of X
and then I am going to want to square
this entire thing, so sin of X,
whoops, I don't want to go there,
sin of X, I have that doesn't close
that parentheses yet, okay that
closes that parentheses, and so I
want to square that, so squared.
There you have it, and then I want
to do DX, so that's that
first blue integral.
From that, I want to subtract, so I'll
get my math function again, I can just
click nine, it does the integral again.
Now I'm gonna go from zero
to pi of this same thing.
I'm gonna go from zero to second, pi.
I'm gonna try to type in that same thing.
I am doing one divided by two, times
open parentheses, three X sin of X
close that, close that, so that's that
and I'm gonna square it, square it.
Then I have my DX, so then I do DX,
and if I typed in everything correctly
I should just be able to
press enter and get the value.
I got 139 point, we're just gonna
round to the nearest hundred, .53.
This is approximately 139.53 square units.